so the idea of completely reading out
the letters of the human genome which
basically meant decoding our blueprint
came to sort of crystallization in the
late 1980s and the reason for that was
the recognition that if we could get
foundational information about our
blueprint it would set up a series of
studies that would help us better
understand human biology and eventually
human diseases that might lead to our
ability to improve human health but that
was an audacious task it was would
require an industrialization if you will
a scale-up of a scientific effort that
was really unusual for biomedical
research you know biomedical researchers
traditionally they have laboratories of
you know six or ten people they work on
profoundly difficult problems and they
like to explore they like to sort of ask
big questions it's very different this
was a very focused effort very defined a
genuine agenda sequence the human genome
to do that was going to require multiple
countries it was going to require
thousands of scientists and was going to
require a number of years originally
slated for 15 years and ended up taking
13 years that is why the analogy to to
the putting a man on the moon has often
come in because the idea that was a very
focused goal we are going to do
somethings going to be a grandly large
project requiring many people with a
very defined goal we're going to put a
person on the moon and so that was
something that biomedical researchers
looked at and said while we never do
anything like that until the Human
Genome Project and I think that's really
the first example in biomedicine of a
defined large-scale project i would say
in hindsight now looking back on it 10
years ago when we finished the project I
think biomedical research have gotten
much more comfortable with doing these
large science endeavors recognizing that
we still need lots and lots of
individual scientists working around the
country and around the world pursuing
important biomedical research problems
but at the same time when you have a big
big question or a big big problem
putting together a consortium of
scientists in a very organized way it's
something we've gotten much more
comfortable with especially in genomics
you